les grands froids ne sont pas encore
installés mais le Premier ministre
Jean-Marc hraud le 1er novembre au
lendemain de la trêve hivernale c'est
voulu clair la politique ne se base pas
sur les thermomètres en conséquence il
faut des centres d'accueil ouverts toute
l'année plus de places d'hébergement et
pas seulement quand les températures
sont négatives du coup la préfecture des
iines a activé dès ce weekend le
dispositif hivernal d'urgence 296 places
supplémentaires ouvertes soit une
augmentation de 39 %
par rapport à la dernière campagne
d'urgence une mobilisation hivernale qui
vient compléter le dispositif permanent
d'accueil et d'ébergement qui compte
plus de 118 places pérennes ouvertes
donc toute l'année outre ce dispositif
le 115 le numéro d'urgence se voit doter
de 4 personnes en plus le SAMU va
augmenter ses maraudes et des
travailleurs sociaux supplémentaires
seront recrutés car la problématique est
globale et implacable pas d'emploi pas
de logement